Il computing responsabile viene inteso
come sviluppare il quantum computing
con la consapevolezza della sua potenza
e dei potenziali impatti quando diciamo responsabile
dobbiamo sviluppare e usare la tecnologia
sulla base di principi predefiniti per aiutarci a prevenire
e mitigare i potenziali danni
promuovendo al contempo soluzioni che siano proattivamente
inclusive e responsabili in IBM
siamo stati guidati da un senso di responsabilità
verso la società per decenni oggi ci definiamo un catalizzatore
che rende il mondo un posto migliore il che significa che
abbiamo la responsabilità di considerare le implicazioni
delle tecnologie che costruiamo e aiutiamo a mettere in uso
mentre sviluppiamo questa nuova tecnologia
le decisioni che prendiamo oggi influenzeranno il futuro
e queste decisioni
hanno il potenziale di avere un enorme impatto sulla società
per esempio potresti dover decidere se perseguire un'applicazione
che aiuta solo pochi portatori di interesse oppure
una che potrebbe risolvere un problema sociale
speriamo che tu come cliente possa pensare
allo sviluppo responsabile del quantum computing per
pensare in modo responsabile può aiutare la tua azienda a instaurare fiducia
con gli investitori e i consumatori
costruendo al contempo una reputazione di integrità
e rispetto presso i tuoi dipendenti
e clienti d'altra parte
può aiutarti a proteggerti da cattiva stampa e multe
e sanzioni in questo video
presenteremo importanti considerazioni sulla responsabilità
da discutere con il proprio team
mentre esplori il quantum computing
e le sue applicazioni quando si tratta di quantum computing
pensare e agire in modo responsabile
significa seguire un insieme di principi
e valori per guidare il tuo sviluppo
e il deployment della tecnologia
per esempio ciò significa essere trasparenti
sia riguardo alle limitazioni che alle capacità
del quantum computing oggi abbiamo un linguaggio
nei nostri contratti che richiede ai clienti IBM Quantum
di utilizzare i nostri sistemi in modo responsabile
e che non usino i nostri sistemi
per scopi nefasti o illegali
li chiamiamo clausole di uso responsabile
e di uso accettabile
questo linguaggio sta già influenzando il modo in cui i nostri clienti pensano
allo sviluppo del quantum
per i loro casi d'uso possiamo
anche influenzare la direzione del quantum computing
decidendo quali applicazioni perseguire
per lo sviluppo e l'accelerazione
per proteggerci da potenziali usi irresponsabili
della nostra tecnologia abbiamo anche sviluppato una robusta tecnologia IBM Quantum
sicura mentre stai pensando a come
e per cosa utilizzare il quantum computing
assicurati di parlare in modo realistico delle tue aspettative
per il quantum computing e le tempistiche
entro cui speri di incorporare il quantum
non presentare il quantum computing
come misterioso ma cerca di spiegarlo in modo realistico
come hardware di computing
che segue le regole della fisica quantistica
assicurati che il tuo caso d'uso per il quantum computing
sia proattivamente inclusivo
e stia considerando tutti i potenziali portatori di interesse
per determinare la portata
di eventuali impatti sociali negativi
assicurati di aver definito principi chiari
e valori per l'esplorazione del tuo caso d'uso
e lo sviluppo grazie
per aver guardato speriamo che
mentre porti il quantum computing utile nel mondo
tu pensi anche a come farlo in modo responsabile.
The the